أجنبي
[موسيقى]
بلا نهاية الكثبان الرملية الشاهقة في
الصحراء بمجرد أن أرى الخطوة المنغولية
بشكل مباشر أفهم لماذا يسمونها
أرض السماء الزرقاء الأبدية،
هذه هي الدولة ذات السيادة الأقل كثافة سكانية
في العالم وهي موطن لواحدة
من أكبر الدول  الإمبراطوريات
في تاريخ البشرية في أوجها،
الإمبراطورية الأخلاقية امتدت من
المحيط الهادئ إلى الخليج الفارسي،
هناك تمثال عملاق لتشنجوس خان
يطل على الساحة الرئيسية، والآن
الإمبراطورية التي جمعها لم تكن فقط
واحدة من أكبر الإمبراطوريات على الإطلاق  لقد
تم ذلك أيضًا في وقت قياسي، استغرق الأمر 25 عامًا
لتأسيس إمبراطورية بحجمها
الذي استغرق الرومان 400 عام لإنشاءه
[موسيقى]
بدأ الطريق التجاري المعروف باسم طريق الحرير في هذا الوقت تقريبًا، ولا
يزال يؤثر على
الاقتصاد العالمي اليوم
ثروة منغوليا المعدنية الهائلة ووفرة
النحاس والذهب الموجودة تحت الأرض
تجذب المستثمرين الأجانب على عمق
ميل تقريبًا تحت الأرض في منجم ريو في
صحراء جوبي، ومن
الصعب جدًا في بعض النواحي
ربط عملية التعدين الأساسية هذه
بتحول الطاقة حتى تدرك
هذا هو كل ما يدور حوله هذا هو
الأصل أو أنه يحتوي على الذهب والفضة
والنحاس بداخله، ولكن النحاس
هو اليوم السلعة الأكثر قيمة
لأنه النحاس الذي
يريده الجميع في
الجغرافيا السياسية، وهو حبل مشدود دقيق
لهذه الديمقراطية الصغيرة المحصورة.
بين روسيا والصين، وتحاول أيضًا
جذب الاستثمار من الحلفاء الغربيين،
وفي العام الماضي أدت فضيحة فساد بشأن
صادرات الفحم إلى احتجاجات حاشدة في جميع أنحاء
العاصمة
أولان باتور، حيث بلغ
التضخم، البعبع للاقتصادات
على مستوى العالم، أكثر من 10 بالمائة، ومع ذلك،
يوجد كل شيء تحت ذلك.  موارد
المعادن والإنسانية التي تعد
بمستقبل عظيم،
منغوليا القديمة والجديدة هي حقًا مكان للفرص،
ليس فقط بسبب الموارد الموجودة
تحت الأرض والمعادن والمجاديف وما
شابه، ولكن أيضًا بسبب
رأس المال البشري الموجود هنا ثلثي  من
السكان أقل من 30 عامًا. لذلك مع
السياسات الصحيحة بشأن الاستثمار في التعليم
والتوجه المستقبلي وشريطة أن يتمكنوا من
إقناعهم بعدم مغادرة
البلاد ولكن البقاء هنا والاستثمار
في منغوليا،
كل شيء موجود للمستقبل